a round of applause for Ukraine's
president as he made an imperson speech
on the world stage political and
Business Leaders taking in vadir
zelinsky's words as he calls for
continued support in Ukraine's war with
Russia which European nation today can
provide a combat ready Army on par with
ours holding back Russia his speech
aiming to put Ukraine at the center of
Defending democracy AS Global attention
shifts to concern turns over a larger
regional conflict in the Middle East
zalinsky met with the American
delegation including US Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin at the world
economic Forum Summit Russia's attacks
on fields on grain Ries on ports in
Ukraine the world's Bread Basket have
disrupted Global markets making food
harder to afford and harming the poor
and most vulnerable lawmakers in
Washington have struggle to reach a deal
on a fresh Aid package the US president
has seen strong opposition to a proposed
billion Aid package to Ukraine Joe Biden
will discuss the aid with Congressional
leaders Wednesday closer to the front
lines the European Union is also seeing
its proposed 50 billion Euro financial
aid package for keev held up it's a
preparation for the extraordinary
European Council on the 1st of February
it's hard work we have discussed many
different issues European commission
president Ursula vline noted 26 members
of the 27 Nation block are an agreement
for the aid but it will move forward
without unanimity
the holdout is Hungary whose leader says
financial supports to Ukraine should be
separate from the EU budget and Aid
should be based on each country's gross
national income Switzerland the host
nation for the world economic Forum
Summit has agreed to host peace talks
it's something the Russian president has
dismissed during a broadcast on Russian
State tv Vladimir Putin said it would be
impossible to take away Russia's
military gains and that Ukraine
statehood could suffer an irreparable
blow if tensions remain high Kyle
Benning Global News